the gyro can experience a human
experience it's just wonderful how we
wake up in the morning human identity
yeah you know the electric love love
just our ability to communicate our
ability to see friends and the beautiful
feeling you gets when you hug or is it
just pheromones is it just chemical is
this anymore yes that's right and love
was what should drive us we are hearing
you and receive love and once we figure
that out and the world is going to be a
lot better we have to if you don't do
that everything else is horseshit you
can have a hundred million dollar house
and a private jet if you know of love
you don't have anything you're missing
the key ingredient that's right you know
it's like having cement but not having
water that's right you know it's right
you have you have the mix lets you know
the water yeah you have nothing yeah you
ain't building any house [ __ ]
yeah I know and and you know we whip and
unfortunately there's so much lack of
love in the world for other yeah other
you know and there's so many people that
want to instead of propagate love they
want to propagate anger and they want to
propagate hate and it's so easy to do
and so many people are dissatisfied by
their own existence that they want to do
that but they don't understand but that
by doing that you are perpetuating this
whole terrible cycle that you've been
caught up in yourself if you go out
there hating on everybody and being
shitty to everybody and throwing all
this anger out there in the world that
you are literally poisoning yourself
there's a there's a wonderful quote
about jealousy that I think also applies
to hate is that it's one of the the rare
things that is ineffective on the person
who's your target but works on you
instead mm-hmm you're jealous
if there's a person out there like oh I
I wish I was living her life and you're
angry at her like you it's not hurting
her it doesn't even affect nobody's like
you dancing in the wind you feel the
poisonous you person to win that was
gonna come right back on yeah it's just
hard for people to understand that
there's techniques and there's
strategies and there's philosophies that
can help you steer through this world
with a happier life and that that is a
big part of it a big part of his
embracing love and friendship and
camaraderie and be nice to people
I think it's much easier to be nice and
to be mean yeah it's hard for some
people because they're not even nice to
themselves well self-love is where it
all starts yeah I don't like yourself
you ain't gonna do too well yeah anybody
else and you know sometimes I wake up in
the mornin truly like myself or what
I've done the neck the day before or in
the past but you know in the end I yeah
I gotta love myself enough to get up and
get going and yeah just don't keep going
it too much this wild crystal vodka no
no everything in moderation
[Applause]